qui
du talent et est équipé
[Musique]
vous voyez les bras qui sont étaient
lundi tout ça ça a été visé devant ils
ont fouillé un peu partout
automatiquement voilà les offrir
on va personnellement je
parce que nos prix natura lien
c'est dommage parce que la marne ancien
magasin fermé pendant la nuit tout bon
bah
c'est un magasin comme tous les autres
c'est dommage qu'ils passent pour faire
manifester à faire casser plutôt que de
manifester mais
si on parle on arrive à gaza
lorenzo est venu pourquoi aujourd'hui
voilà base c
en brèche à paris et prévoir un petit
post c'était quand
la grève d'aujourd'hui c'est un
événement est aujourd'hui comme vous
voyez ces images là comme vous retrouvez
devant cette boutique est ce que ça vous
évoque bah c'est honteux parce que les
gens qui sont ceux qui travaillent là
dedans ils sont pour rien donc je veux
dire on peut être pour quelque chose
l'avenir paraît l'emploi qui voulaient
des poubelles il commence à peler les
choses pour quoi faire même au niveau de
l'assurance vie mais aussi axa
l'étudiant qui bosse là bas ils ont bien
aussi je peux comprendre leur révolte
mais même qui commence à tailler un peu
par tout le monde et encore on pourrait
passer mais vraiment cassé des cassé les
vitres et retourné des agences comme ça
sert à rien
d'envoyer mélange tout comme maintenant
on met
des couleurs ces distinctions
s'était pas fait un peu tout et
n'importe quoi vous donner c'est vrai
que c'est ça faire remonter les prix
avaient alors fait aujourd'hui il ya
plusieurs plusieurs revendications
pouvoir d'achat
les législatives
venez vous aussi aussi rouge que malgré
tout c'est s'arrête avant vente de
bienvenue de la vie démocratique du pays
mais je vois aussi parents qui met aussi
beaucoup de
[Musique]
à
au niveau des revendications ben non on
est là parce que ça nous parle parce que
c'est important de se mobiliser après
entre-deux-tours pourri et que on veut
que ce quinquennat soit pas et c'est
tranquille avec quand on regarde le
problème de maquereaux on se dit que
forces mobilisées se bouger les fesses
on est on est pas jusqu en a pas juste
votée macron pour
pour qu'il applique son programme on l'a
fait pour bloquer l'extrême droite et
puis on veut pas que qui est juste
l'application de son programme sans
contre-pression opposition à la faute on
n'a pas fait ce qu'on avait commencé
l'histoire
[Musique]